if I have 1 little time for 1 beer on Friday
can still play football on Saturday
then that is the ideal working week
this is the voicemail of young political The Hague
leave 1 message after the tone
what do you think of the term per generation
and it falls on place and yes
because it is quite unfair that you are just in 1 group
who has not received that basic grant
we always call it that
but honestly I find it quite 1 difficult term
because it's not like it happens to you
and oh you're out of luck
and actually it is the result of bad policy
it is actually not only about the loan system
because it is very difficult to get 1 permanent contract
and affordable housing
broader than just the loan system
young people are currently quite unlucky
you can do better
pay attention to the rights I have as a catering employee
and thereby also transfer the minimum wage
the first one
we don't want to raise the minimum wage very much
we want right
from the burden side to see if we can make it lower
I think it's ridiculous anyway if you are 18 or 21
are that you earn less than your colleague
who does the exact same job
we also want the minimum wage to simply go to 16
euro goes